- For the first time ever,
first year associates
at New York law firms, that
is people who just graduated
from law school, are going
to start out with a salary
of $200,000 or more.
Here's how this works.
There are some fancy
law firms in New York.
It used to be Cravath, now
it tends to be Milbank Tweed
that set the salary that lots
of other law firms follow,
and this time for the first year ever,
Milbank Tweed is offering
first-year associates $200,000
plus bonus.
Fifth year associates
are gonna make $300,000,
and while that sounds like a lot of money
and it is a lot of money,
remember that number one,
they're going to have to live in New York,
which is incredibly
expensive, and number two,
they're probably have to
bill at least 2,400 hours,
which means they're
probably going to be working
at least 3000 hours a year,
which means about 60 hours a week.
So yes, these are white collar jobs,
but this is hard work
with very long hours.